[Música]
gran deja parcialmente a ciegas el
organismo internacional de energía
atómica este organismo de control
nuclear de la onu confirmó que teherán
apagó las 27 cámaras que vigilaban las
actividades dentro de las instalaciones
nucleares iraníes éstas habían sido
instaladas como parte del acuerdo de
2015 para así permitir al país
desarrollar energía atómica para el uso
civil un motivo más de preocupación para
el máximo responsable del organismo irán
dice que también planea instalarse entre
jugadoras avanzadas que le permitirán
enriquecer rápidamente más uranio una
escalada más de las tensiones sobre el
acuerdo nuclear firmado con occidente y
rusia en 2015 que fue aclamado como un
gran avance en las relaciones con irán
pero recibió un duro golpe cuando el
entonces presidente donald trump retiró
a eeuu tres años después de manera
unilateral salvamos entonces a nuestro
primer invitado el día el es niño
rodríguez experto en comunicación
política e inteligencia analista quijote
club portal de geopolítica y estrategia
gracias niños por estar con nosotros una
vez más en directo américa de france 24
y pregunto qué implica el retiro estas
27 cámaras de las instalaciones
nucleares iraníes
pues en principio no implicaría mucho en
lo que sería el nivel de monitoreo de
las actividades hay que tener en cuenta
que estas 27 cámaras suponen el 20 por
ciento de las cámaras que tienen la
institución de la energía atómica para
monitorear todo lo que está sucediendo
dentro de las instalaciones iraníes con
lo cual tenemos todavía un 80 por ciento
de cámaras que siguen operativas con los
cuales se puede estar vigilando cuáles
son las actividades que de una manera
general están están tomando en este
sentido han quitado de estas 27 cámaras
porque estaban fuera de lo que era el
acuerdo de vigilancia estaban fuera de
lo que eran los tratados que se habían
llegado a acordar y eran digamos una
manera de demostrar la buena voluntad
que tenía el país iraní el país persa
con la organización para mostrar sus
fines pacíficos de desarrollo de energía
nuclear
qué es lo que se puede entrever que es
de una manera ya no
factible lo que se puede estar mirando
es la del grave conflicto que está
viendo la gravedad y asociación de
objetivos que está viendo entre la
organización de control de la energía
atómica y el país persa en este sentido
así que es un elemento bastante más
grave lo que no se ve que lo que es la
retirada física de las cámaras digamos
que tanto hablando de estas 27 cámaras y
las otras que tanto limitan estas
cámaras y esta vigilancia pues el plan
nuclear iraní este desarrollo nuclear de
irán
tampoco mucho la verdad
tenemos que tener en cuenta que todos
estos acuerdos se tienen que basar más
en la buena voluntad de las partes que
en lo que es una vigilancia estricta
hemos visto muchas veces como el país
iraní ha limitado a prohibido el acceso
a los investigadores a los observadores
de la organización de la energía atómica
y tampoco ha sucedido nada administramos
viendo cómo ha habido una información un
tanto confusa ha habido información
errónea ha habido información que no ha
sido contrastada y que sin embargo está
sobre la mesa a la hora de evaluar todos
los procesos de desarrollo de la energía
nuclear en irán qué es lo que lo que
puede suponer en esta nueva etapa pues
simplemente estamos viendo que de una
manera bastante evidente no parece que
se quiera llegar a un acuerdo ahora
mismo y parece ser que va a haber más
actores dentro de la mesa de negociación
digamos que irán entonces estaría
dispuesto a llegar hasta las últimas
consecuencias está hablando de la pues
el entierro de este acuerdo nuclear de
2015 en uno además le quiero preguntar
cuál es el estado actual de este acuerdo
el acuerdo evidentemente de una manera
obvia de una manera pública y mediática
luego no confío eeuu tampoco podemos
tratar con culpando ahora mismo a irán
de abres de no cumplir un acuerdo que
había sido roto que realmente por todos
los actores firmantes y de hecho por él
por el impulso por el impulso al del
mismo
ahora mismo la situación que tenemos con
él
con el plan de problema y relación con
él con el acuerdo nuclear es simplemente
un acuerdo roto han estado saliendo unos
elementos del pasado sobre las las
trazas nucleares de unos supuestos
sitios donde se desarrolla la actividad
nuclear que tampoco ha sido contraste
contrastado más allá de unas imágenes de
satélite de desatender son imágenes
comerciales de ese límite es el de sharp
el de los públicos y tenemos que tener
en cuenta que es demasiado evidente el
intento que hay por factor pda llegaron
a un acuerdo no podemos estar ahora
mismo hablando de que vaya a haber una
continuidad en el acuerdo y tampoco
podemos estar hablando de que irán vaya
a parar en sus pretensiones de alcanzar
digamos un desarrollo más más estable de
energía atómica sea para el uso que sea
con estas pretensiones de irán supone el
país una amenaza nuclear
al momento no de momento lo que puede
llegar a pasar dentro de unos años pues
ya va a estar dentro de la voluntad el
propio país de meydan quiera para el
desarrollo de su de su energía nuclear
está claro que sería un elemento
disruptivo que rompería el equilibrio o
el desequilibrio de poder que hay en la
región porque tenga que tener en cuenta
también que irán es un poder que sería
hegemónico en la región si no llega a
ser porque hay otros actores limitando
limitando su influencia en la región qué
pasaría con unir un irán nuclear pues
muy seguramente se acabarían estresando
o se acabarían balanceando hacia hacer
unas posiciones u otras todos los demás
actores tanto en euroasia como como en
oriente medio hay que tener en cuenta
que si sería algo disruptivo pero no es
tampoco
un elemento que pudiese se pudiese tener
en la mesa de momento y lleva muchísimos
años intentando desarrollar su programa
nuclear tanto civil como militar y de
momento lo único que está teniendo son
son bastantes trabas para conseguirlo
puede llegar a conseguirlo en un futuro
por supuesto que lo va a hacer y late la
ciudad que tienen los iranís muy
seguramente haya que apuntar a que lo
vayan a tener cuál va a ser el resultado
de este de este acuerdo pues también va
a depender bastante de la voluntad que
tenga el resto de actores en la sección
como para reconocerlo con el actor
generalmente de una manera histórica de
una mara económica y de una manera
demográfica tiene en la región claro un
niño ahora pongamos esto en el contexto
actual con una terna en ucrania el temor
de un conflicto nuclear que significaría
entonces para el mundo digamos el
fracaso de revivir este acuerdo nuclear
con irán
está claro que es difícil hacer de
predicciones de lo que de lo que va a
suceder sobre todo cuando todo este tipo
de asuntos tiene que haber un elemento
que es indispensable que es el
secretismo en las negociaciones nosotros
ahora mismo sabemos lo que lo que nos
está mostrando de una manera pública y
con esas informaciones podemos entrever
cuáles son las direcciones y cuáles son
digamos los los objetivos de cada actor
está claro que con la situación que
tienen ahora tenemos ahora mismo en
ucrania el otro polo de conflicto dentro
del
mira es algo que sería bastante todas
las fronteras de rusia y ya se ve que
hay planes o por lo menos se han
presentado diversos diversos planes para
expresar las fronteras norte desde irán
y en este sentido se acabaría
arrastrando a todos los demás países de
la región hacia un conflicto multipolar
bastante bastante bien planificado
quedaría por ver cuál sería la posición
de turquía que se condene sobre supone
que tendría que ser el monitor de todo
lo que es la estrategia de estrés en las
elecciones
a nuestra nada claro que se puede llegar
a suceder y si llegase a suceder está
claro que se supondría una escalada
bélica a nivel global bastante
importante